Nathaniel's asking hey Evan can you ask
Stephen Kelly what books you recommend
or suggest about taking risks in
business thank you I've read a load of
books and I would say actually now a lot
of it is they come back to the basics of
trust rinsing and and they all say the
same thing so whether it's i read the
google books work rules pretty recently
that's pretty cool around disruption and
also you know how bears all started at
amazon that's pretty cool as well i am
but i think you know that what you need
to do in all these books is say yeah
what does that apply to me but but also
you don't want to be a clone you don't
want to follow in someone else's shadow
you want to be your own entrepreneur you
won't want to be your own you want to
have your own moon mission you want to
take moonshots and that's what makes you
special that's what makes you different
and i would say it comes back to a lot
of it chattering things do you research
around customers and it's so easy
through social now to get amazing
feedback you know in nanoseconds about
your product or service and listen
listen listen listen listen and then
change your goals and then you'll you
will be a world-beater you'll grow fast
what's your favorite book of all time
right love this but it speaks to I just
love disrupted a lovely blue and I have
with the status quo to kill a
mockingbird ha it's my favorite to kill
a mockingbird and it speaks to
everything that you know even if
whatever you are what 50 60 years ago
and all the great changes through the
civil rights movement that have changed
the world a little bit but you know I
think all of us mantra knows not only
what I pursue our passions but if we can
challenge inequality and injustice then
wow you know it's not about just
building a great business and clocking
out the rest of the world we've got to
be part of the world we can't exclude
ourselves